le tracé du rer vélo a été dévoilé en
partie ce lundi 30 novembre lors d'une
conférence de presse organisée par la
région ile-de-france et le collectif
vélos qui regroupe 38 associations
si la guette son goût bonsoir soir vous
avez vous êtes avec nous pour parler de
ce projet et il y a cinq premières
lignes prioritaires qui ont été données
lors de cette réunion
oui c est une première étape du rer b un
réseau express régional vélo la région
ile-de-france veut pousser ces habitants
à utiliser ce mode de transport
les premiers comités de pilotage donc
été mise en place concernant cinq lignes
sur neuf nommés de a à e
comme vous pouvez le voir sur la carte
la b3 paris massy saclay plaisir passera
par trappe et se terminera donc à
plaisir est là à un paris la défense
cergy-pontoise passera par sartrouville
et conflans sainte honorine dont le
détail est donné par philippe wullens et
membre du collectif du travail du rer d
savard emprunté un trajet qui l
empruntent le pont le nouveau pont sur
et hall en chemin de fer épaules à
houilles ça va rejoindre sartrouville et
ça va traverser à maisons laffitte
il ya toute la traversée de la forêt
jusqu'au pont la passe à la passerelle
de conflans la passerelle jaune de
conflans sous le pont de la 184 qui est
une passerelle piétons vélos ensuite on
ronge les quais jusqu'au pont de fin
d'oise pour entrer dans la ville
d'andrésy et prendre les quais en
direction de morcourt et alors ce projet
célia doit répondre à plusieurs
objectifs dont les deux principaux c'est
la continuité et la sécurité
c'est exact traiter les disponibilités
cyclab est une priorité
pendant ce temps il ya 6000 kilomètres
de confettis cyclables c'est à dire
qu'il n'ya pas un véritable réseau et
c'est à ce problème qu'il faut s'atteler
pour pouvoir créer 650 km de pistes
cyclables sécurisées et pour un maximum
de sécurité il faut une signalisation
j'imagine oui il faudra rendre visible
la ligne rer b pour les cyclistes mais
aussi des autres usagers pour cela de
signalisation s'entendait de sites
envisagés un marquage au sol avec un
logo commun pour toutes les lignes vers
hervé l'eau et utilisait une
signalisation verticale sous forme de
panneaux ou d'auto thème
en tout cas ces cinq axes devront être
aménagées entièrement d'ici 2025
merci célia pour ces précisions